nevada trump victory campaign hosted a  get out the vote rally earlier today  supporters and volunteers met at their  henderson field office on the last  saturday before the general election  congressional district candidates were  there they also went out to talk to  voters in the community  the president's son donald trump jr will  make a stop in reno and las vegas  tomorrow  meantime local trump supporters also  gathered near aliante in the 215  to rally for the president today around  50 people showed up to support their  candidate  they walked on the sidewalk of the  pedestrian bridge waving flags and  posters  local republican candidate mac miller  was among those supporters  he is currently running for assembly  district five